what's going on guys this is rob and you
guys really really liked the videos that
we did on annihilus and dr doom in terms
of the mcu villains so we're gonna keep
this going for a little while longer and
kind of see how people respond to it and
in this video i want to create an
argument on why the marvel cinematic
universe needs mephisto now i know in
like a lot of the videos that we've done
recently where we've talked about doctor
strange 2 and even the videos before
that how we really presented this
scenario where marvel was basically
taking or at least the mcu was taking
the beings like mephisto and nightmare
and all those guys and kind of just
rolling them all up into the single
package that we call dormon right so
he's kind of a jack of all trades he
plays the role of mephisto plays the
role of nightmare basically messing with
mortal people and wreaking havoc across
the universe or even the multiverse and
just kind of calling it a day but let's
say we deviate from that for a second
and let's say that we focus on the idea
that like mephisto is a being that could
actually appear in the marvel cinematic
universe i think it'd be great to have
him there but we'll also talk about one
of the big drawbacks when it comes to
having mephisto in the mcu and how it
could actually be difficult to have him
there so first things first let's you
guys who are unfamiliar with mephisto
and i'm sure most of you guys have the
idea of him by now if you've been
watching
literally any of the tv shows from
marvel since one division
but for those of you guys who don't
mephisto is one of the many iterations
of what we would call satan in uh in
marvel comics there really is not a
tried and true satan in marvel comics
the closest we got to that was during al
ewing's immortal hulk run when we
learned about it being called the one
below all but at the end of that story
we ended up learning the one below all
was basically what happens when the one
above all hulks out right so
like the one above all being god so what
happens when god becomes the hulk he
becomes the one below wall
just this huge ethereal being right just
ridiculously powerful op but it wasn't
really like the one below all was like
some being out there created by the one
above all who like challenged his reign
and then was cast out of what you would
call heaven and confined to what we
would call hell that wasn't really the
case right so when it comes to these
different ideas of the hell dimensions
these are what are called the splinter
realms and the splinter realms were
basically just part and parcel to what
was called the dark dimension at one
point in time in marvel comics now in
the old magic comics from back in like
the
80s i think maybe the 90s basically the
way it was explained in really kind of a
hand wavy fashion is that somewhere
along the line some sort of event took
place and basically fractured the dark
dimension where it only had like a giant
chunk and then the other remnants were
kind of splendored out into a whole
bunch of other smaller realms the result
of this is that these different beings
these hell lords fear lords like
nightmare people like that the dweller
in darkness and so on and so forth they
ended up basically taking over these
little pieces these little shards if you
want to call them that of what used to
be the unified dark dimension and then
making them their own little realms now
the question has to be asked here why is
it that someone like mephisto doesn't
conquer the realm of someone like
nightmare and absorb it into his own so
this was answered last year in a story
called spirits of ghost rider the mother
of darkness or i'm sorry mother of
demons and basically what it said is
that all these different hell lords had
entered into a kind of pact right you
stay away i stay away that sort of thing
and that for the most part when they
round up people's souls that it's really
more like bragging rights right which
demon has the most souls now in terms of
mephisto again we don't really know his
origin part of this is because of the
fact that he's literally a god of lies
so can you really even believe his
origin if he gave it to you and the
other part of that is because he's the
god of lies marvel has had mephisto tell
his origin multiple times over the years
in marvel comics so the reality is there
is no tried and true origin to mephisto
i mean i kid you not in that same story
right spirits of of ghost rider and so
on uh that basically mephisto was
presented to us or at least the the
claim was made that mephisto was the
serpent in the garden of eden that
basically tricked eve into eating the
apple from the tree of knowledge of good
and evil and then in turn passing it to
adam and then getting the two of them
basically kicked out of eden right so
essentially it was presented that
mephisto was basically the serpent right
he was satan but the reality is that
mephisto is not now in terms of like
these different hell lords there are a
lot of them right so like muspelheim for
example the realm of surter that is one
of the hell dimensions uh but the thing
about this and this is what's the real
kicker here is if you wind the clock
back when it comes to marvel comics you
talk about the idea of death and the
role mephisto plays it wasn't always
that way initially when marvel first
launched it first became marvel and he
had like the old thor stories all you
had was tales of asgard written by jack
kirby it was basically this idea that
essentially everybody who dies goes to
the realm of hella unless you die in
honorable combat and then you go to
valhalla and then they introduce like
mistress death and a whole bunch of
other people what the introduction of
mephisto did is it basically told us
that where mephisto has his own realm of
hell and literally tortures and torments
the people in there that it's not
uncommon for mephisto to leave his realm
to show up on earth strike deals or
bargains with mortals and then in turn
collect their souls at a later point in
time when they basically die and then
take their souls to his own realm of
hell all the hell lords do that every
single one of them do that certain does
that and like damon hellstrom does that
and mephisto does that they all
basically do that now what makes
mephisto unique and what makes him so
intriguing is really his personality his
character and like watching him fail a
really good example of this is that in
mobile comics mephisto's routinely tried
to corrupt the soul of the silver surfer
and it cannot be done the silver
surfer's soul just cannot be corrupted
this guy is just a pure incorruptible
being so it's kind of like this on
running subplot that marvel has with the
silver surfer that's been happening for
decades right for like 50 years where
they've been trying to get mephisto to
like corrupt the silver surfer soul and
it just never works but by and large
when mephisto shows up on earth what
he'll do is he'll basically present you
with what it is that you want most right
so let's say that you wanted like a
billion dollars right that mephisto
would in turn come to you and say hey so
i can give you a billion dollars right i
just need to know if you're willing to
make a little bit of a wager or
something like that right some kind of a
bet or whatever it is you'll enter into
a kind of game with it now in the end
you'll get that billion dollars but
there'll be a caveat so maybe the
billion dollars is locked and locked in
a bank account that you don't have
access to and then when the time comes
when you die the mephisto will take your
soul right he tricks you lies to you
that kind of a thing that's why whenever
you see stories where like doctor
strange confronts mephisto which you may
very well see in doctor strange too that
whenever that kind of situation unfolds
those individuals who are familiar with
mephisto will be very very very careful
about the deal they enter into because
he's very particular with his words and
how he phrases things says everything
right so if mephisto says i'll give you
a billion dollars the caveat to that is
that once you come to collect mephisto
will say well i never told you when i
just told you i'd give you a billion
dollars like that kind of a thing right
so haven't you said that let's talk
about the mcu you know it's kind of kind
of transition to the marvel cinematic
universe so the reality of this is that
what makes mephisto so cool what would
make him so interesting is you could
literally see people like getting into
bargains with mephisto and then use that
as a means to expand the marvel
cinematic universe a perfect example of
that is the mother of doctor doom right
we talked about that in the last video
that we did about doctor doom so kind of
a nice little way to reference back to
that video that we did but the reality
here is that dr doom's mother had struck
a bargain with mephisto in order to
attain the power necessary to cast out
the baron who had basically ruled the
land her people existed in so her people
could take their land back the reality
is she didn't understand what she was
getting into she basically tried to stop
the baron she failed and then she was
killed and when she was killed mephisto
took her soul that's the entire basis
behind why doctor doom does what he does
so introducing mephisto in that way is a
great way to potentially introduce
somebody like dr doom into the mcu more
so than that mephisto has the wolverine
effect right so if you introduce
wolverine into the marvel cinematic
universe what you could do is you could
say he's had all these moments over the
course of his timeline all these little
things that he's been a part of right
like the opening sequence to what is it
uh x-men origins wolverine that not very
good movie but the opening sequence to
that where like wolverine was in world
war one then he was in world war ii and
all that kind of stuff and you basically
got a kind of three or four minute uh
montage essentially of all the things
that he'd been doing over the course of
his life you can attribute a lot of
things that have happened in the mcu to
the actions of mephisto right maybe it's
mephisto who go to thanos into wiping
out half the life in the universe maybe
mephisto was the one who told him about
the infinity stones in the first place
because if unless my memory isn't
serving me correctly i don't think we
ever figured out how it was that thanos
learned about the infinity stones he was
just after them so again it may be
something that i've forgotten here in
the moment that just doesn't occur to me
i'm sure that if there is a reason there
you guys will tell me down in the
comments section but the important thing
is you could tie mephisto into that
right just all these little moments
these things that have happened over the
course of the mcu the biggest problem
with that is you'd have to be very
careful about how you do it because what
you don't want to do is cheapen
something right you don't want to
cheapen a thing just because you want to
introduce mephisto so this is probably
like a really terrible example but like
in that moment when black widow like
jumps off basically sacrifices her life
in order for clint barton to get the
soul stone when they were on vormir if
they were to be like well mephisto was
the one to get her to do it one that's
stupid and then two it would cheapen the
hell out of it because the significance
of that moment was that natasha knew the
sacrifice that she was making more
important than that is like everything
we learned about her personal life so
like her sister elena and all that kind
of stuff and it's just like okay damn
she left all that behind she sacrificed
all of that
just to basically ensure the soul stone
would be passed on to clint barton so
they could literally save the entirety
of the universe right all of creation so
that would cheapen the sacrifice of
natasha romanov but you get what i'm
saying in terms of like being careful
about how it's done now the other big
issue with introducing mephisto into the
mcu and this is really the tough sell on
making it work is mephisto only matters
when he's with other people mephisto
only works when you have him making a
bargain with someone else right so
mephisto making a bargain with johnny
blades and then turning him into the
ghost rider those are the only real
times that mephisto ever works right
doctor doom doctor strange teaming up to
get dr doom's mother's soul back from
the fisto that's an example when
mephisto fought galactus in his own
realm that's an example right there was
one point where basically i think
mephisto either kidnapped it had
something to do with the silver surfer
it's it's been 15 years since i read
this story so you're gonna have to bear
with me my memory is a little fuzzy on
this and i'm kind of doing it spur at
the moment but in effect mephisto was
trying to corrupt silver surfer's soul
and then either he had kidnapped silver
surfer or frankie ray or somebody and
then took them to his realm and so
ultimately galactus followed suit and
i'm pretty sure it was a silver surfer
he'd taken because he believed that he
could corrupt the silver surfer soul in
his own realm where he's the most
powerful kind of a fun fact the longer
mephistos away from his own realm of
hell the weaker he becomes but he had
taken silver surfer to his own realm and
then in turn galactus followed suit to
get the silver surfer back and then a
great big huge fight broke out between
the two and had the battle lasted any
longer it probably would have destroyed
the universe that's how powerful
mephisto is right he's just ridiculously
op but again i use the example of like
mephisto and thanos and the infinity
stones because those of you guys who are
familiar with the infinity gauntlet
storyline know that mephisto was kind of
manipulating thanos so that he could at
some future point in time take the
infinity gauntlet for himself right that
was that was his goal but again that's
the nature of mephisto he works better
when he's bouncing off people when he's
making bargains with people so having
mephisto in the mcu i don't really see
him being introduced as like the main
bad guy in the same way that like thanos
was or like the way kane the conqueror
is or any other villains that we will
see in the future of the mcu he's not
really an in-your-face kind of villain
he's an operate from the shadows behind
the scenes swindling people making deals
the whole spider-man one more day
storyline that we have that we are like
obliged to mention because somebody in
the comments is going to be like you
forgot about spider-man one more day uh
that we we have to mention that so in an
event like he's one of those guys that
operates behind the scenes right from
the shadows not really in your face
there aren't very many instances where
mephisto's like i'm going to conquer the
world and then just like shows up and
just starts attacking the avengers it
doesn't really happen all that often in
fact i don't even really think that's
happened at all it'd be cool if it did
but like that doesn't really take place
right he just manipulates and that sort
of thing so if you did see mephisto in
the marvel cinematic universe likely
there would be illusions to him like
what we've seen so far building up to
some definitive moment when mephisto had
actually meddled in the affairs of
people right like manipulated somebody
into doing a series of things that's why
right now doctor strange two in the
multiverse of madness if ever there were
a time to introduce mephisto into the
marvel cinematic universe now's it right
if it doesn't happen here it will
probably never happen the only exception
to that is when they introduce ghost
rider but as far as we're aware agents
of shield is still in continuity and
mephisto was never really seen in ghost
rider robbie reyes got his powers from
the good samaritan which was either
johnny blaze or danny ketch i don't
remember which one they came out and
said that it was i'm pretty sure it was
johnny blaise because he's the most
popular although whenever people think
of ghost rider they're actually thinking
of danny ketch in terms of the look but
the thing about this is that uh that
that mephisto was not introduced there
so assuming that it's all in continuity
and we end up seeing robbie reyes from
agents of shield rolled over into the
greater marvel cinematic universe that
there won't be any reason to believe
mephisto would be seen there either
unless they like reboot the whole
ghostwriter mythos and then you would
see mephisto introduced but beyond these
two instances right doctor strange two
or the introduction of ghost rider at
some point in time if you do not see
mephisto under those two circumstances
you probably never will which kind of
makes sense to a degree i mean i think
at the end of the day we can all kind of
admit it is a bit of a tough sell that
disney
would introduce basically satan
[Laughter]
into the marvel cinematic universe and
sign their name to it uh it pissed off
all the christians here in the united
states so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
let me know what you guys think about
seeing mephisto in the marvel cinematic
universe and thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace i almost got a new peace peace